we all have to die what's important is
what you do before you go
[Music]
i'm the bad man i have been for a long
time
that's three people likely killed with
the same weapon what's that found him on
the floor
your shooter's losing his mind
anything else i can do for you the room
number again
the retainer for your services is 10
million dollars
very carefully the girl stays alive
you're answerable to me
a 13-year-old been relocated to a group
home was not here last night
yes what's wrong you're sure
hugo thinks it's a pro settling scores
trafficking vince and sierra i can't
keep doing your job for you who is this
you're too slow to make them pay what
they did to children they're not doing
anything about it
he's taking out the traffickers that we
couldn't
he's interfering with an international
investigation
you said he wasn't going to be a problem
i've done crazy things
why don't you and i just have a talk i
know you're not well no time for that
if i'm dead you'll never know the truth
stand down
i want to believe that you're a good man
vincent
if i can't finish this you have to
but they have to be punished
which side of this do you really want to
be on
i want justice
we all have to die what's important is
what you do before you go
[Music]
[Music]
you